[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i was doing drugs i was staying at ari
shafir's old place dude before he
freaking
uh did that uh epithet for kobe or
whatever he did whatever it's called
before he spoke at his funeral yeah yeah
and uh
uh i got locked out of there dude i had
to climb they have like these communal
gardens or something
it's like you know sometimes no they
don't
they do though they have like there's no
communal cars
in the backyard to get into his place
like bro it was insane it was just crazy
yeah yeah i knew it was just a lot bro
you're sweating this is a lot going on
for even somebody that's not i feel like
i almost got wrapped up in one of your
stories it almost happened just right
there
bro it almost happened right there it
sounded like
it sounded so romantic and fantastical
that i was like oh tell me about new
york city
[ __ ] communal culture that's welcome
see there's a [ __ ] communal garden or
somebody burned a building down
the dude anyway i had to jump a fence i
just sneak around the back of his
building to get in
yeah yeah i just want to be free also to
say what i want to say like last night
on stage joey diaz had a stage
a joke that had a bunch of racial slurs
in it right yeah ones that we would
all not even probably see on this
podcast except you because you work with
a lot of black people you might be
willing to drop oh i don't do the n word
huh i don't do the animal oh i don't do
it dude unless you do
you know what i'm playing i'm just
joking yeah
i mean i quit doing it probably about
four years ago when everybody else did
really yeah you got off i mean yeah i
was like i like how you quit porn after
this this train is going nowhere
i'm tan bro i look better tan bro oh you
do
i think i look well you come in a lot
more and i'll be honest with you bro
you come in a lot more i think mexican
bro or [ __ ] beach slavic
you know you know what i'm saying like
beach uh
croatian croatia
you crack them open dude there's a
couple brothers
there's a couple brothers in the rib
cage eating oranges bro
russian little russian dogs oh okay
you're gonna get a brown one eventually
yeah oh there's sheldrick
yeah it's like the reason it's all
advertising it's all advertising like
the r kelly [ __ ] is coming out again now
because he's broke so he can't pay
people off
oh wow yeah it's like imagine how yes
how stressful that must have been though
just juggling all the pedophilia stuff
you know just busting around the [ __ ]
warming the urine constantly and busting
it around
you know like he didn't like to produce
new york
in age oh i better be sure he did he
seems like a guy that likes an aged year
nice age jaren oh yeah that's dark isn't
it yeah
but it is what it is it's funny though
it is funny we had a question that came
up
uh um raleigh miles here with us today
and uh and why don't you bring something
up riley we got a fella that from the
mta i know that brought in a question
here
it's an urban gentleman kind of suburban
gentleman
no urban this guy's urban oh urban
gentlemen
there we go that's it huh can you ever
move back to kelly
well let's see what this guy has to say
[Laughter]
sorry brandon the bike the podcast is up
it's just going to be some sting brandon
oh it's been staying for a couple weeks
over there
you and chris you better eat some weird
[ __ ]
what's on the menu what's on the menu
next
they're probably getting freaking
ridiculous over there
dude like i'm flying in
for a delicacy
get out of here get the volume on riley
no hold on so you're not going back bro
you're not going i'm going back dude
[ __ ] you bro this is a question turn the
question on right i can't even throw my
mic because
there's no sun coming out either even i
don't fix the damn deal i couldn't even
throw my mic away because y'all made fun
of me for the way i laugh on the podcast
who did you
shut the [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
who said that who did that one i did
that's awesome bro
find a better way to fix it riley yeah i
know that's what i'm trying to do okay
i was crying sorry man this question was
probably these kids you got working here
bro
they're like 12 years old i don't know
it's getting bad you got a little peter
pan factory going on
dude what's going on that's the one
thing you find out
outside of la in new york dude it's
young boy
we got a question dude your mic is
looking for you bro
it's just getting further
the other day you might put up a wanted
poster to venture you
on it have you seen
it's just you in the picture you're
hanging in front of me somebody gotta
prank me where they just like cement it
in i go to push it away
it's the new shake weight
god i'm sure he did 212 mikes today
i i do you feel like that things are
better off than the media makes them
seem to be
yeah dude that's this like i feel like
i'm asking you all the questions that
like
i have questions too and you're like how
the [ __ ] do you still have these
questions no
no i'm not it's okay it's good i'm
knocking your question i'm saying like
i could i assume you're asking me this
question because you already feel the
way about it
you already feel like yeah but i get
overreact oh so yeah i'm
not knocking your question i'm agreeing
with your sentiment
that i'm assuming you have yeah right so
like the jesse smilet situation is a
perfect example it's like when we found
out it was fake
right people went but things like this
happen every day
no they don't that's what i say they
never
happened yeah they and people were
literally tweeting they're like
there are lynchings every day where yeah
somebody told me that there's still
slaves in south carolina someone told
me like are you [ __ ] crazy possibly
but it's only because you have people
maybe somebody that's hard of hearing
and is [ __ ] committed to their job
i mean but nobody's just like signing up
anymore
there's a bunch of guys like what's
emancipation i don't know what that
means they really chose the biggest word
to say they really did
they did it on purpose they're not gonna
know what this means we're gonna get a
few years after the [ __ ] is slippery
two or three more years emancipation
proclamation they just kept using bigger
and bigger words
that's so true because we had chris
hanson yeah everybody kept hitting me
like yo
tell him to pay back theo i was like for
what like did
i thought they said tell them to pay
back theo
and i didn't know if like you were
involved in like to catch a predator in
some way
or no i've never done anything like that
okay so like no i'll be honest bro i had
one you should show up here though one
girl sent me a message on ig and i said
you are
too young for me now
could he she work for you with the rest
of the [ __ ]
children that you have in here
how old are you i'm 22. there you go
he's 22
uh he's 22 he's hairless too all right
and look i'll tell you this
never uh he's hairless so he looks
younger got his first pass
so like if we knew where let's say dr
pepper was giving our money so dr pepper
was like
i gave you know a million you know dr
pepper you gave a million dollars to
uh republicans i'm gonna drink yeah
tab or something exactly right but they
also give a million dollars to the dems
right so the dems are gonna say how
could you give a million dollars to
these people who
want to stop a woman's right to choose
right and dr pepper's like
i just want to sell cola yeah i don't
they just let me sell cola better it's
not about abortion
right but they're gonna be like no you
don't believe in abortion dr pepper
yeah you know what i mean you're not an
abortion doctor or whatever
so so like so so and then if they give
the money so he's already fine i give
them money democrats now you go to the
republicans like
you want to kill babies dr pepper you
want to kill them
until they're up to two years old that's
the latest ruling i heard you can kill
them until they're up till
two it's nuts dude yeah that's the year
after pill
it's like what the [ __ ] is going on when
is it in
when does it end the seven year after
pill how well behaved on a plane though
oh
dude you break out a couple of those in
the [ __ ] hand how old is the kid
doing a lot of crying on this like
i'll ask you this yeah well what
happened to me chris hansen was this
yeah and there was
we put him up i'll ask you this this is
what happened
probably impossible to talk to you
you're impossible guys we will do this
for a living we promise
we both do this for olympics i don't do
this
okay tell me what happened with chris
hansen because i got inundated with
messages people are upset at me
for interviewing this guy because i
didn't know
that he i guess ripped you off or
something there was
extra charges at his room where'd you
put them up
we put them up at the four seasons
that's the that's you know i mean
you know look bro jose you don't made it
hey you don't made it bro four seasons
look bro we put them up at least the
three seasons
oh we got all four a quarter of those
charges
now we put him up with the three seasons
he ordered the fourth that's what i'm
saying brother
how much extra charge is about 1200 for
autumn
that's what it was no including room
there was extra charges so that's where
it became a discrepancy where it
seemed like he was trying to not pay the
extra charges
okay and we kind of agreed on what the
charges would be so yeah
he felt like there was maybe gray area i
don't know i'm not accusing him
it just seemed obtuse at the end i
thought
because the story i heard the way that
you know the game of telephone changes
[ __ ]
is that um he tried to sneak out the
hotel
and you had like an employee chase him
down
yeah like on some not so fat like
remember your show sir like
like how ironic he leaves the hotel he
gets arrested
and and then forced him to pay the bill
before he left
that's what i heard i swear to god i'm
not making up any of this i swear to god
and i got like 10 or 20 messages
uh here's what happened i had an
assistant at the time yeah
and she uh was make i had her she was
checking out what the bill was what was
going on yeah
and she was literally talking to the
woman on the front desk as he was
leaving the hotel
and so it just so happened it just so
happened and so the
she like it was had to apparently speak
with the lady and say well can you
make you know get a hold of him and get
some charges at him we got to get some
charges out of them yeah you know
so yeah but with that said i mean
the dude has done a lot for humanity and
i don't mind putting him up for another
couple nights isn't it
you know what i mean like there's a
little part of you that's got to go like
he stops so many pedophiles
oh totally like you shouldn't have to
pay for the hotel yeah but you were like
he should have to pay a little
he didn't stop enough he didn't stop
what happened to me
what if the whole thing wasn't set up
where were you
when i was a kid yes what if that's the
new show
where were you when i was a kid
and it's just people just trashing
people
rolling up on chris hanson and john
walsh and just sitting them down
and saying look man where are we going
okay you know you nice to go over out
there to l.i.e to that other place out
there they had
dude that's a crazy one new york the the
the room will be
30 feet by two and a half feet you're
right
yeah corridor on a yacht ship
like the norwegian what is it called the
northern cruise
2d it was 2d comedy
dude nate bargassi murdered in that room
bro oh i could see that
i could see he's so calm yeah nate is
that calm man i bet him donating blood
it could be
it could be an afternoon yeah yeah but
it could be he donates double
it's a while though his blood don't even
care to go
what are we doing here nate you know
ain't no right way just the wrong way